さやってまいりましたステマのコーナーです
だめだステマって言ったらもうステマじゃねーよマーケットのコーナーです
皆さん大福好きですか僕は好きじゃありません
親馬鹿4っていうとってなんかちょっとおばあちゃんっ
別れ所
ちょっと降り立つしてないじゃないなぁってとこがあると思うんですけど
若者はやっぱシュークリームとか食べようと思ったんですけど
1ねあれ3つ売れるなあと思って買ったのがダメだイプ
2種類あるんですよこしあんと愛べっち部は今食べたら結ばになるな
矢田虫歯
食べたらつ歯磨きしながら食べればいいよいいよこしあんかな
食べますまだ慣れてるでしょ
なんか大福とかなぜまた何か私のばあちゃんの味がするとか思ってるでしょ
ロー明朗ウェイ農園くって気づく内のサッカーボールみたいなたんっ
じゃ食べられます
第二
おぢばなりたくないなぁ
ていません
うまいこれローソンの南下しへてるコーナーにあるんで
kk の大福が美味しいんですあんこそんなしすごくないですよ
それはや勝って感じですねアンカーんかスターまずはすごい嫌いなんでそれでも美味し
いって感じるって
貴様のも
美味しいって感じると思います100何円なんだよ
買ってみたらいいと思いますよ
最初思ったんですけど僕って湖面コメディ系動画ですかねぇ
サイエンス5まで僕なんか払いが求めてないんですよ
なんか
なんだなんて言うんだ
それは分からんぞわからん
コメディじゃない切らせなきゃでもう
使って旅ログ系ですかね時々コメディをするんですけど
僕そんな
がっつい笑いを求め苗や橘が大事ですよ
なが笑うのが一番いいと思うんですけど
コメディじゃない気がします
まあコメディーですけど難しい竜一ですねコメディ的に美ログみたいな感じにしておき
ましょう
お守た粒あんの方を食べます
ん
いっ
ああああああ
ん
美味しいんでしょ
6 c んですけど
粒餡との違いがあっ
いまいち分からないみんな夜更かし言っちゃダメだよ
ポテトチップスが違うは何をと戦だ
なんでもないよん
goo
9分
me